[Musique]
boucles et lille quelle île manhattan
si tu fais le mal tremble deux tireurs
qui ont de l'entraînement car ce n'est
pas sans fin qui prend 10 les pays du
fait s'abattre la colère de dieu sur
celui qui fait le mal je vais les
retrouver
si on choque pas ces types dont les
trois ou quatre heures ils disparaîtront
le quantum offert 21 qu'on permette de
sortir de l'île bouclé lille kalil
manhattan
lyon
ils m'ont dit que tu exécutes les tueurs
de flics magnifique on se coltine un
malade de la gachet le feriez bien de
faire attention en disant à malades de
la gâchette c'était un piège appel ce
que je viens de faire
si tu prends ce chemin on pourra
regarder par dessus son épaule toute ta
vie
je préfère regarder le diable en face
tu est celui qui exécute les tueurs de
flics
je vais les retrouver
combien de policiers 8 le pire carnage
juin 18 ans les avaient été appelés pour
un cambriolage
j'ai choisi c'est pas pour rien je vais
les retrouver
si on chante pas ces types dans les
trois ou quatre heures ils disparaîtront
le conte est offert il y à 21 points qui
permettent de sortir de manhattan
on monte des barrages
on arrête tous les trains ont toutes les
stations de métro
ensuite on inonde l'île de flics ça pas
de sens le 17 et 30 kg et on se retrouve
avec trois cents
il se passe quoi là je veux la vérité
c'est toi
ils ont juste été une tête brûlée celui
qui exécute les tueurs de fric
personne le coup
moi
ce